[SPEAKER_01]: 5.30 p.m. on the 2nd of Wealsun as Paul and Jude are taken into the barracks by the garrison commander and the other men are taken care of.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you go into this area and...
[SPEAKER_02]: So to be clear, our 20 men, which we lost none to death, at least get bandaged.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, they're going to go and take a short rest, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right, take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so basically, Paul, you come into this office area and...
[SPEAKER_01]: The surgeon says, this is Paul Rivera, this is the nephew of Lord John.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was here to speak to Lord Fairwind regarding why we have not had a signal from the island after that storm.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I respond, the signal was sent, but it was inappropriate.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was not per its match.
[SPEAKER_01]: What has happened?
[SPEAKER_01]: The garrison commander says, the helm has been taken, as have most of the lighthouses.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Lord Fairwind?
[SPEAKER_01]: We've heard no word.
[SPEAKER_01]: We think he's still up in the helm, hopefully, in the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well defended place.
[SPEAKER_01]: It would be very hard for someone to take that area.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the nature of the attackers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not saying about the shark people, of course, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Unknown.
[SPEAKER_01]: The troops you've seen, the red-faced men.
[SPEAKER_01]: The hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that what they're called?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what they're called.
[SPEAKER_01]: But also they're coordinating.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Haugen have been attacking the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, two ships that were in the bay have been taken to the bottom of the sea.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have any contact with the Eastern Lighthouse or whichever one was the other one?
[SPEAKER_01]: The one not... We've had no contact from the Lighthouses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their signals have been off as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: The barracks was not assaulted.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, we know that the helm has been taken.
[SPEAKER_01]: How?
[SPEAKER_01]: We do not know.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's been a strange ship in the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: When your ships were coming, it moved off around the island to the far side.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many men do you have?
[SPEAKER_01]: Here we have 100, the garrison.
[SPEAKER_01]: The full garrison?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, we've lost no men here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So 120?
[SPEAKER_01]: 22?
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant says yes, the full contingent that we have is 120 at this point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, we have two options.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can either play the long game and wait it out, which is definitely risky.
[SPEAKER_00]: But seeing as how I'm here, Gian will probably respond with a day or two.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the long game.
[SPEAKER_00]: The quicker action as we go to one of the towers, the sun will work.
[SPEAKER_02]: What I would suggest is, is the tower that we dropped people off to, that was actually between, maybe not between, because I don't think you said that, is the tower that Gouge and the troops sent to.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it looks like
[SPEAKER_01]: Where's Monmurg on its map?
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg is that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's the garrison.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the island that Gauge was sent to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this would be the tower that we would need to take if we wanted to communicate to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_02]: Either one of these two.
[SPEAKER_02]: If we did not hold the citadel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Either of these two.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is where the citadel is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: What I think is because they have sea creatures, I describe also to the captain of the garrison the same thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because they have sea creatures, we don't know the level of forces.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're not just facing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, the men of Lord Fairwind have remained true.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I try to, you know, lift them up, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: But because of that, we do not know the level of the forces.
[SPEAKER_02]: We could send one man here to try to inform our troops, but we should attack and force this because we have to communicate to Monmurg that they need to send more troops because we are up against
[SPEAKER_01]: What did you call them?
[SPEAKER_02]: The shark people?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sahuagin?
[SPEAKER_02]: The Sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, because we're up against the Sahuagin, we'll send one troop here, or, well, maybe a squad of five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Five guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: The garrison come in and goes, who is this man?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's an advisor of mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, and the sergeant... Well, let me say some things to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: With the sahuagin able to attack the island, any movement onto the islands that have the lighthouses will be very dangerous.
[SPEAKER_01]: They can move through the seas easily, and they're swarming around the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've seen what they've done in the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The truth is, it is strange to me that they attack Helm Island, because historically they've never come here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Since they were defeated hundreds of years ago, they've left this island alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, it is strange that their activities are such as they are.
[SPEAKER_02]: But not given the current climate of being embargoed, being isolated.
[SPEAKER_01]: This would be the next logical step.
[SPEAKER_01]: Helm Island is magically protected from the sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something has changed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, you're right, but we can't just sit around and do nothing because of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have to do something.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm saying that what we do has to be very, very... We can stay here in the barracks and defend it.
[SPEAKER_01]: These red-faced men will not be able to take it from us, but if we walk outside, we will be slaughtered if we go to the beaches.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are the sahuagin more of a threat, or are the red-faced men?
[SPEAKER_01]: The sahuagin are much more dangerous.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are much more of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: The red-faced men came off the boat, as I told you, and there's not much more than, I would say, a hundred or so that have come onto the island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, theoretically, I've seen one of the lighthouses.
[SPEAKER_02]: Could I initiate a fireball, just like I did on that one tower, theoretically flame?
[SPEAKER_02]: Potentially everybody within the tower?
[SPEAKER_02]: What I'm trying to think of is that if I had to move here...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think you can get everybody in the tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, let's say that if I got over half...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not going to talk about theoreticals in combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to see it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't really know.
[SPEAKER_01]: The lighthouses are tall.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're like 80 feet tall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so there are multiple stories.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't think you would just be able to explain it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I might be able to do it, but maybe if it's 80 feet tall, I can only handle like 20 feet of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if they had a whole bunch of people at the base, no go.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they had a whole bunch of people at the base and I hit the base...
[SPEAKER_02]: The top part would survive.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, well for now we need to heal up and we need to rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have any way to signal?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have no troops that control any of the other towers?
[SPEAKER_02]: All of the towers have been taken over by the enemies.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in fact, I don't think it is the red-faced men, the hobgoblins as you call them, that have done it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is the sahuagin that I figured out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So where did the hobgoblins come from?
[SPEAKER_01]: That boat that I talked about.
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: That came from the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The attack happened last night with the fog.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do they have any way to signal at all to any of the three towers from the barracks?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because that's where we're at, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: We've been doing that already.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: What I want you to signal is I want you to spell out the word Karmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand if all three towers see it, spell out the word Karmurg, because we have dropped off 30 people to this tower, and that would be what they would recognize.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if they respond to us, we know that they will be true.
[SPEAKER_02]: These two, they will give us gibberish.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they respond when we send out the words Karmurg,
[SPEAKER_02]: To this tower, they might be able to respond to us as we dropped off 30 marines before coming into the harbor and engaging.
[SPEAKER_02]: If the battle in the harbor is lost, these 30 marines might still prevail.
[SPEAKER_01]: When the sun sets, we can do the signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: They'll see it at that point.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't have anything they will be able to see until the sun sets, but we can get a message to whoever is in the tower over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I assume this just means that you're letting them know that friends are here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: If there's other messages that we could, you know, assume or communicate, I don't know that the Marines would be able to... We can send messages to them if we know they are friends, or we do not want to...
[SPEAKER_02]: So send Karmurg friend questions.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then if we have a response that is acceptable to you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then we can communicate with them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Good plan.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's all I got.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have much else.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're wounded.
[SPEAKER_01]: You should rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: We will get food.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're safe here for now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Again, the sahuagin will not climb the walls, and these hobgoblins are far too...
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not numerous enough to basically assault us in this place.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am an elven mage.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just need four hours to meditate to regain my spells.
[SPEAKER_01]: You will have four hours of safety here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hopefully it will be nighttime then though.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps we can get a message to your friends and they are still alive and coordinate with them.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they respond with any acknowledgement, either with the words Gouge, Jude, if they seem to respond with a person's name,
[SPEAKER_02]: Then I think that we can inform them of the entire situation, meaning give them greater detail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Certainly, if I'm mistaken and they're the enemy, they will already know this stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let us wait till I fall.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's an hour away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then we'll proceed.
[SPEAKER_02]: I must go meditate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you go to meditate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to do a short rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is how a short rest works.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have three one-die eights.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll one of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six hit points, you get back six hit points, and one of your one die eights has been used.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can do a short rest three times a day.
[SPEAKER_01]: It takes an hour to do so.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, you only have those three dies, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: As you go up levels, you get more.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what you can do is, let's say you get wounded slightly in the first conflict, you take a short rest, and you have like
[SPEAKER_01]: If you decide to use one die eight, you get one die eight hit points back.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then later, if you want to do it again, you can go back and use two more two die eight for a different short rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can do that three times.
[SPEAKER_01]: After three times, or if you use all your die eights during the rest, you have to do a long rest to get all of them back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to use any more one die eights?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll it.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's four more.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have nine off you now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to use your last one?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have one hit point off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you clean the wounds and eat, and you realize that the spear thrust that you thought was incredibly wounding actually was not that bad, and your leather armor managed to deflect it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a bruise.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the cut itself looks badly, but it's pretty superficial.
[SPEAKER_02]: It did worse damage pulling it out.
[SPEAKER_01]: The scrapes on your neck that came from the claws, they're superficial as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're left with healed wounds, basically cleaned up, looking fairly good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've used three dice though, so you have to mark off one, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have no more.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if you have to do a short rest later, it could be bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I haven't suffered any damage, so I don't need to.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've not suffered any damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, one thing you could do is this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could do a arcane recovery and get back three spell slots.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or you can start trying to do a long rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've actually only cast three spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: I cast Firewall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three spell slots.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three spell slots.
[SPEAKER_01]: So one third level spell slot, three first level spell slots, and so on.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you could get back that guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: For an arcane recovery.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, but that would be the difference between one hour or four hours, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what I'm trying to say is, if you want to do an arcane recovery and do a short rest, you can get one of the spell slots back, and then you can see what happens with the signaling.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or if you want to start the rest now in four hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I will actually, so what I'll do, if I can, I'll do the shorter version, take back one of my three, third level, and then if nothing happens, try to meditate or trance more later.
[SPEAKER_02]: But be ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I've only got, yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're running out of Jesus.